[Music]
if you have a data set in bigquery that
you wish to copy within a region or from
one region to another
you can do so without needing to extract
move and reload the data
in this video you will learn two ways to
copy a bigquery data set using the cloud
console
both options require three preparation
steps
first review the required permissions in
the documentation page linked below
to ensure you have the roles needed for
the source data set
destination data set and for creating
transfers
second you must create the destination
data set where you would like the copy
to live
in this tutorial we will create the
destination data set in the same project
however this is not required third you
must enable the bigquery data transfer
service in the same project as the
source
data set from the navigation menu choose
apis and services
and dashboard click to enable apis and
services
search for bigquery data transfer api
then click enable navigate back to
bigquery using the search bar
now we are ready to see the two options
for copying your data set
option one is using the copy dataset
icon
this method is simple quick and perfect
for a one-time dataset copy
select the data set name of the source
data set that you want to copy
click the copy data set icon in the copy
data set dialog
select the project id and destination
data set id
optionally check the overwrite
destination table box if you want to
refresh or overwrite
the data and schema of the tables in the
destination data set
click copy a permissions window may
appear to give the bigquery data
transfer service permission to manage
your dataset copy
if so click to allow you can see the
progress and view details of the dataset
copy under transfers
back in the bigquery console you will
see the tables populate under your
destination dataset once the transfer
completes
consider deleting the old data set to
avoid additional storage costs
if that makes sense for your use case
now let's see option number two
using the transfers ui this option is
best if you want to copy a data set on a
scheduled basis
in the left-hand nav click transfers
click
create transfer in the source drop-down
choose data set copy give the transfer a
name
in the schedule options section you can
choose when the transfer will execute
and also you may set the transfer to
repeat at regular intervals
we will choose to start the transfer
immediately and schedule it to execute
weekly
now choose your destination data set in
the drop-down
you must copy in the name of your source
data set and project id
remember to use your project id not your
project name
check the overwrite destination table
box if you want to refresh all data in
the destination data
set you can also receive email
notifications
if and when a transfer fails click save
you can see progress and view details of
the data set in the transfers ui
once the transfer completes you will see
the tables populate under your
destination data set
back in the transfers ui make sure you
use the three dots to delete or disable
the recurring transfer to avoid ongoing
charges
there you have it two different ways to
copy data sets depending on your needs
at general availability data copied
between regions is built at the same
rates as pricing for compute engine
network egress between regions
bigquery sends compressed data for
copying across regions so the gigabytes
build may actually be less than the size
of your data set
all standard bigquery usage charges for
storage and querying will apply on the
copied data
more information on copying data sets
and pricing is linked in the description
below
happy analyzing